c'est un courrier qui l'a reçu il y a
cinq jours le tribunal de police de
Dijon signifie à Victor un enseignant
syndicaliste à la retraite sa mise en
cause pour avoir participé à un concert
de casserole on se sent délinquant alors
que non on ne l'est pas il lui a demandé
de répondre s'il reconnaît ou non
l'infraction participation à un
rassemblement interdit ce qu'il refuse
la sensation c'est que ce gouvernement
devient autoritaire l'Union Locale du
syndicat solidaire a récolté une
trentaine de témoignages similaires il
serait même 8 à avoir reçu une amende
pour émission de bruit pourtant atteinte
à la tranquillité du voisinage son
syndicat envisage de porter l'affaire en
justice
pour une fois
je ne vais pas fan des casseroles mais
là c'est une honte il y a même pas eu de
contrôle d'identité pas de procès-verbal
on sait pas d'où ça vient et ces gens
parce qu'ils peut-être qu'ils ont été
repérés effectivement par des caméras de
surveillance sont sanctionnés parce
qu'il tapait sur une casserole à un
moment faut arrêter j'espère que les
avocats vont casser tout ça alors il a
raison parce que le délit émission de
bruit c'est ridicule
un rassemblement illégal à 68 euros
c'est pas non plus une somme qui me
paraît disproportionnée quand on chante
c'est pas là c'est comme ça
il y a manqué les lois on veut un peu
d'ordre et puis voilà ça me semble pas
non plus d'un 68 €, c'est pas non plus
400 €, quoi moi ce qui me choque c'est
qu'on trouve le temps pour résoudre ce
genre d'affaires qui ne sont pas graves
qui te font mal à personne et qu'on met
1000 ans à à traiter des affaires avec
des gens qui sont des dangers pour la
société on a quand même le sens la
sensation qui est justice à double
vitesse dès que ça concerne la
contestation du gouvernement c'est
sanctions immédiates tout de suite ou
alors à retrouver les images sur les
vidéos surveillance etc ça va beaucoup
plus vite pour ça que pour des trucs
beaucoup plus importants excuse-moi
c'est le contraire c'est le contraire
quand on est soi-disant en colère et
qu'on n'est pas qu'on est contrôle
gouvernement on peut rentrer chez
Vuitton comme imaginons si moi et ma
mère on rentre chez Vuitton toutes les
deux et qu'on fout le bordel on serait
tout de suite en prison là il rentre à
combien non mais c'est vrai dès qu'on
est en colère on a tous
il y a pas trop de monde quand même ça
marche bordel de ouf quand même
non mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
[Rires]
mais non mais vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
je pense que ça va c'est parce que j'ai
adoré l'exemple si on rentre ma mère et
moi j'ai vu tout et qu'on fout le bordel
ça ferait peur non mais là attention il
y a des loubards
[Rires]
mais il suffit
on fout le bordel sur le périph et tout
ça il y a rien on voit très inquiété des
amendes et il faut quand même pour des
teintures
partout c'est à chaque coin de rue
maintenant il suffit d'être en colère
c'est très bien comme ça
non les gens en colère n'ont pas non
plus tous les droits donc voilà
Philippe Lavil
[Rires]
amende il a jamais rien reçu je
comprends pas je suis au cas de poids de
mesure surtout surtout qu'ils étaient si
vous avez des pancartes si vous n'avez
pas le côté Asus c'est que j'étais
beaucoup plus que 18 à taper sur des
casseroles mais du coup ils ont regardé
les vidéos ils sont dit tiens qui
reconnaît dans le sur la bande il y a
tiens lui je sais qui c'est c'est des
doutes comme ça donc ils ont leur que le
18 je crois donc ils en ont donné 18 il
y en a plein d'autres mais il savait pas
que c'était donc ça c'est complètement
un avocat
comme les Black Blocs est-ce que tu veux
faire Benjamin ta tête un avis on fait
une heure que tu as pas parlé
[Applaudissements]
il est dans son rôle là
[Musique]
on est en train de disserter savoir si
c'est bien ou pas
honnêtement on parle de ça c'est il y a
pas plus grave dans la vie
bah oui c'est ce que je pense
on devrait s'agiter beaucoup plus pour
de plus que pour ça
combien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
soyez quoi là
la dernière fois hein
vraiment alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a
tout va bien
[Rires]
pour l'instant tout va bien
c'est totalement disproportionné et donc
injuste c'est pas non plus des hooligans
alcoolisés quoi donc il faut pas
exagérer je comprends pas je trouve que
c'est en fait c'est c'est pas bien pour
pour tout le monde en fait c'est pas
bien pour celui qui a l'avance c'est pas
bien pour le gouvernement c'est pas bien
pour la justice c'est pas bien pour la
police c'est pas bien enfin voilà donc
c'est bien pour la France voilà
exactement c'est ridicule